На той час це був найбільший конфлікт в історії людства.
Щохвилини війна забирала життя 4 солдатів, не кажучи вже про поранених.
Сто років тому закінчилася Перша світова. Які наслідки ця війна мала для Східної Європи?
Що Україна здобула, а що втратила, чи, можливо, одночасно: і здобула, і втратила?
Чотири великі держави не вижили у цій війні і зникли з карти світу.
Австро-Угорська, Німецька, Російська та Османська імперії розпалися.
Натомість нові держави з'явилися у Східній Європі.
І майже всі почали боротьбу зі своїми сусідами.
Чи-то за територію і сировину, чи-то за доступ до моря.
Крім того, у грі нова ідеологія - комунізм.
Для Росії Перша світова стала катастрофою.
У царя було достатньо солдатів, але недостатньо оснащення.
Значна частина бойових дій відбувалась на українських етнічних територіях,
які тоді належали Російській та Австро-Угорській імперіям. Українці воювали з обох сторін.
У 1917-му була повна деморалізація і розчарування у війні.
Царський режим повалено.
Більшовики приходять до влади й підписують мирний договір з Німеччиною.
Але миру немає. У Росії розпочинається громадянська війна.
Країна - кілька років у хаосі.
На півдні Європи багато народів хочуть заснувати свої власні держави:
боснійці, серби, хорвати, словенці.
Але стає відомим таємним договір між італійцями та державами-переможцями.
За допомогу під час війни вони пообіцяли італійцям важливі стратегічні території у Хорватії.
Італія хоче забрати свої порти та хорватське узбережжя.
Саме там, де Хорватія прагне заснувати свою державу в 1919-му.
Це змінює плани південно-східних європейців.
Щоб протидіяти Італії, вони формують спільну державу - Королівство Югославія.
Але народи нової держави не уживаються разом.
Протягом десятиліть накопичується конфлікт і через 75 років відбувається кривава громадянська війна.
Сьогодні народи Південно-Східної Європи мають власні держави.
Складна ситуація і з українськими землями.
Одразу після закінчення війни виникає суперечка з  поляками: зокрема щодо Львова.
Типова ситуація для всієї Східної Європи: у центрі міста живуть поляки, а в районах навколо - українці.
Де провести межу?
Зрештою, місто відходить до Польщі, але потім знову стає українським.
Як і між Україною та Польщею, прикордонні суперечки у Східній Європі
часто пов'язані з національною приналежністю.
Села лише за кілька кілометрів одне від одного
розмовляють різними мовами і бачать себе частиною іншого народу.
Різні ідентичності та кордони на карті - рідко збігаються.
Так само і в Болгарії. Після Першої світової країна була серед тих, хто програв.
Вона повинна була відмовитися від частини територій,
виплатити репарації переможцям та прийняти багатьох біженців з прикордонних регіонів.
Схожа ситуація й в Угорщині, яка втрачає більше половини своєї території.
Припинення вогню у листопаді 1918 року завершило цю велику війну.
Однак це перемир’я не принесло тривалого миру для Центрально-Східної Європи.
Україні на нетривалий період вдалося відновити свою державність.
Але потім українські етнічні землі були поділені між радянською Росією,
Польщею, Румунією та створеною тоді Чехословаччиною.
Втім все одно зросла національна свідомість серед населення,
а українці здобули досвід створення власних збройних формувань.
А нині, через 100 років після закінчення Першої світової,
які наслідки тих подій досі відчуває Україна?